so one of the Republican members on this
house select committee that's
investigating the January 6th Trump
riots Adam kinzinger uh essentially
admitted to Wolf Blitzer last night on
CNN that other than one or two
Republican elected officials none of
them actually believe that Donald Trump
won the 2020 election it's not a
surprising admission but I would make
the point that it's actually worse that
despite not believing it they continue
mostly to allow the claim to spread
publicly and we'll get back to that but
before we look at the video just as a
sort of reminder there was a proposed
January 6 commission that was going to
be 911 style is the way it was described
it was proposed months ago it was going
to be truly bipartisan in the sense that
we would all sort of agree that it's
bipartisan which meant that there were
going to be five members chosen by the
Democrats five members chosen by the
Republicans the chairman uh would be a
republican a Democrat rather because
Democrats control the house
Vice chair would be Republican every
subpoena would have to be signed off on
by both the Democratic chair and the
Republican Vice chair Republicans said
no whole bunch of reasons why they said
no many of them bogus we've talked about
it before So eventually we get to this
house select committee which is
investigating and in this one House
minority leader Kevin McCarthy said
here's five Republicans were putting on
it two of them were Jim Jordan and Jim
Banks who really should be Witnesses or
they're potentially accomplices in the
riots they have no business
investigating them and so Nancy Pelosi
the Speaker of the House rightly said
they can't be on the commission
ultimately
we saw Republican Adam kinzinger and
Republican Liz Cheney placed onto this
panel and
um on after the first day during which
we heard from four different uh members
of Capitol Police last night Adam
kinzinger was interviewed by Wolf
Blitzer on CNN now it's really important
as we watch this clip
Adam kinzinger is talking about elected
officials don't believe Trump really won
this is not about Republican voters
that's an important distinction which
we're going to talk about in a second
but let's start with the uh interview
here and um very very important points
made we can get to answers have any of
your Republican colleagues I'm just
curious uh actually privately said to
you good work I support you yes oh yeah
is that just one or two is it a handful
or or give us a it could be a ballpark
number you know because over time I
don't know it's there's a lot of people
you know and uh that come up and say it
and it's not any of the ones that you
know go on TV and and spout the big lie
and then say it it's the ones that are
staying more quiet that I think
appreciate the stand
um but it's a lot and look what the
thing to keep in mind save one or two
maybe out here nobody and I think it's
very important to repeat nobody actually
believes the election was stolen from
Donald Trump a lot of them are happy to
go out and say it was are you still
comfortable being a member of the
Republican Party have you given any
thought at all maybe of switching
parties as you uh are you gonna have to
seek re-election next year yeah no no
look I'm a republican at heart right I
was a republican way before Donald Trump
since I was six years old I believe in
the values I'm six year old republic by
the way we could explore that
six-year-old Republican but let's not
right now fighting for and I believe
that a party was such a great Rich
history deserves to have people even if
it's only a couple of us at the moment
in their fighting to restore the soul of
it so I'm gonna fight hard for that so
let's let's think about this I I
essentially believe that Adam kinzinger
is right here I think there are almost
no actual Republican elected officials
who think Trump won the 2020 election
they're not good people because
privately they don't believe it they're
actually bad people I would say I mean
you know it's a simplistic term but what
the point I'm trying to make is I would
respect them if they came out out and
said this is a lie this is the Joe Biden
won we might not like it I'm not a
Democrat but Joe Biden won this is
Republicans saying this privately
believing that Joe Biden won but not
coming out and saying it and allowing it
to be perpetrated and perpetuated and
and uh blown up and Signal boosted by
your colleagues I would argue that
that's actually even worse and I know
that there are some people who will hear
this
and they'll say I knew that most of
these Republicans had a good head on
their shoulders I knew it they couldn't
really be so dumbest to believe that
Donald Trump actually won the election
they're they're actually they're okay
people no no no no it's even worse that
they are allowing something like that to
be continually spread discussed signal
boosted and reported as if it's news
when they don't actually believe it and
the most infuriating part and this is
where we have to distinguish between
Republican politicians and Republican
voters
it is not true that Republican voters
don't believe it the Republican voters
do believe it they are pulled on it
regularly and so these Republican
elected officials who maybe they
privately know that Donald Trump didn't
actually win
they are allowing or even participating
in misleading their constituents because
it keeps them politically relevant it
keeps them on Trump's good side which
they think maybe they're going to need
in 22 or in 24 if they know it's a lie
then why are they spreading it or
allowing it to spread and it's because
they know that a lot of the voters
believe it and the voters believing it
probably is beneficial to them in terms
of getting themselves re-elected and
um the the the voters believing it is
having a real impact you know when when
I drive by this house a few miles away
that has this huge 12 foot wide by you
know 10 foot tall Trump flag in the yard
that says Trump won they really do
believe it and we see the polling and we
see that tens of millions of these
people believe that Donald Trump
actually won so great there are
Republicans who are in moral or amoral
enough
that while privately they know Donald
Trump didn't actually win they either
say publicly that he did or he might
have or they shut their mouths and allow
the Republican Party voters to continue
spreading that idea
um they aren't good people because they
privately know the truth they are bad in
the sense that they don't come out and
say hey guys I might disagree with
Democrats on taxes abortion foreign
policy whatever but the president of the
United States is Joe Biden because Joe
Biden won the election period fair and
square end of story and you know I'm not
surprised to hear Adam kinzinger said
he's willing to say it unfortunately
many of his colleagues may not believe
it but they're still willing to allow it
to spread like a virus within the
Republican Party
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and daily energy I
have struggled with sleep at times in my
life I've tried many different things
and Rise has been really useful it
tracks your sleep debt which is how much
sleep you essentially owe your body
tracks your general rhythms helps you
understand your daytime energy levels
and Rise can improve your sleep and
energy by giving you personalized
feedback about your sleep metrics when
you should go to bed when you should
wake up in terms of optimizing at your
personal rest it can even tell you
things like how long should you expect
to be groggy in the morning based on
when you wake up you can make
science-based improvements to 16
different habits that will make you feel
more rested every day and most rise
users start feeling that way in the
first five days including me and Rise is
still helping me every day it's great
it's based on real sleep science very
few things are as important as improving
your sleep go to rise science.com Pacman
to try rise free for a week the link is
underneath this video